well hey that's right
[Applause]
one three four five six seven eight nine
ten okay
here we go I've wondered for a very long
time how Joe Rogan this guy who
describes himself as a professional fool
went from hosting a game show where he
eats cockroaches with contestants to
becoming the host of perhaps the most
popular podcast on Earth
[Applause]
and you're going no and that's how you
die now listen I am not a Joe Rogan
listener well at least I wasn't before
this story but by now I am because by
now me and my team have listened to a
lot of Joe Rogan if you didn't know
whether or not people agree with you or
disagree with you I think that'd
probably be better overall for people I
wanted to understand where this guy came
from what his deal is what does he say
during these like two to three hour long
episodes that are listened to by
millions of people because For Better or
Worse he is influencing a lot of people
so let me show you how an average Joe
like Rogan can sit around getting high
talking to his friends and somehow get
millions of people to tune in now I know
know that talking about Joe Rogan can
cause some controversy but at the end of
that round
[Music]
before we get into it let's thank
today's sponsor the internet is becoming
kind of a dangerous place like people on
the internet who want to do bad things
and steal from you are getting better at
doing that luckily there are tools that
exist to help protect you one of those
tools is nordvpn nordvpn started as a
VPN but it's much more than that now a
VPN by the way allows you to connect to
the internet securely via a different
country this allows you to do a lot of
things like watch Netflix in another
country or to even get price discounts
on things because there's so much price
discrimination based on your geography I
use nordvpn kind of like second nature
it's just one click away it kind of runs
in the background but again nordvpn is
much more than that these days in recent
years in response to all of this more
sophisticated criminal activity on the
internet nordvpn has developed a suite
of threat protection tools tools that
allow you to be more safe on the
internet with just one click they
recently introduced nordpass which is a
password manager you can store all of of
your passwords securely in one place or
nordlocker which is a place where you
can store all of your files securely on
the cloud backing them up and keeping
them safe and being able to access them
from anywhere Nord has become a ad
blocker and a Tracker blocker with one
click you can stop intrusive trackers
from following you on the internet you
can block intrusive ads Shield yourself
from malware while you're online and you
can generally stay safer while surfing
the internet this sounds like a lot of
things but it's all packaged into one
thing nordvpn who is the sponsor of
today's video they're a long time
supporter of the channel I'm very
grateful to them not only for sponsoring
our videos but also for the product that
they make it's a good product I use it
all the time and I'm grateful for it so
if you want to try this out nordvpn
which by the way is like the fastest VPN
out there you should click the link in
my description it's nordvpn.com Johnny
Harris there is a 30-day money-back
guarantee you can try it out for up to
30 days and get all of your money back
if it's something that you actually
don't think is very useful to you
clicking that link helps support the
Channel but it also gets you in on an
extra extended subscription to nordvp
you get the two-year plan plus four
extra months links in the description
thank you nordvpn for sponsoring today's
video let's get back to Joe Rogan okay
so it's 1987 and here's a 20 year old
Joe Rogan taking a guy down with a
spinning back kick at a Taekwondo
competition always moving to new schools
always dealing with new kids and I
wasn't big and I didn't know how to
fight and I got picked on and I didn't
like it so I said I wanna I wanna figure
out how to fight and eventually he got
really good at it I was competing from
the time I was 15. I just threw myself
into it that's all I did every day and
then One Summer Night in 1988 when he
was 21. he went to an open mic night at
a comedy club in Boston your legs are
sprawled out on the bed like Bambi
trying to walk in a frozen lake and
banging your head against the headboard
make love his friends goaded him to get
up on stage and perform a stand-up set
it must have gone really well because
soon after Rogan moves to LA to make it
big in comedy by the 90s he was showing
up in TV shows as the goofy lovable
comedic relief because the light's
better over here
better over here but this sitcommy thing
wasn't his dream he loved comedy and
fighting enter UFC Ultimate Fighting
Championship
thank you
[Applause]
okay so it's the late 90s and now Joe
Rogan is like a UFC commentator
personality interviewing Fighters
backstage this is actual footage of his
first appearance they are anticipating a
wipeout in the finals yeah and I mean
this guy's good like he's got such a
Magnetic Personality even back then by
the time he was in his 30s it was the
2000s and Joe had proven to be a
talented host and Entertainer and he was
chosen to host a show where contestants
would be pushed to their limits to test
their fear it was a show aptly named
Fear Factor
Fear Factor I mean I remember this from
my childhood the show had like a huge
impact on our media culture
I think it kind of laid the foundation
for Sensational reality TV it was
disgusting and sometimes just downright
horrifying but honestly it was brilliant
because it was impossible to look away
Sherry relax
so Fear Factor was like the big leveling
up for Joe Rogan you know what again
very fortunate it was a great gig plenty
of money and it was all good and it
definitely helped my stand up because it
gave me money too it gave me the the
ability to not worry about like having
money in the bank and by the end of the
early 2000s Joe had a lot of experience
he was an Entertainer he was a comedian
he was a host he was an actor he had
built a hefty network of interesting
people it was charismatic and tough and
funny and hard-working all of the
ingredients he needed for his next move
podcasting on Christmas Eve 2009 Joe and
one of his comedian friends recorded a
two-hour podcast it was a sprawling
conversation covering everything from
conspiracy theories to game addiction to
sensory deprivation tanks it was
honestly a good omen for what this show
had become he called his podcast The Joe
Rogan Experience kind of a nod to Jimi
Hendrix now remember in 2009 podcasts
weren't really a thing yet you had a
bunch of like sort of radio shows that
were making it onto podcast Like This
American Life or Planet Money stuff you
should know but this was all very new at
the time but that changed when people
could stream podcasts on Demand with
their new little Internet connected
pocket computers right from the
beginning Joe Rogan's show was fast
prolific and consistent uploading
multiple times a week and by the end of
his second year on the show he had had a
bunch of big names as guests we've done
everything wrong we these were young
male elephants they're the fastest
moving creatures I think in the wild
once they get going and uh they hate
bright like bright shirts which of
course we were wearing uh they don't
they're spooked by people holding
implements uh which of course that's
what we were doing and they particularly
don't like being herded by people one
you know thousandth of their weight at
the beginning they were mostly Comedians
and Fighters I'm thinking about Tom
Cruise and Scientology there is a man
using every ounce of what Scientology is
offering to make himself the best
available man that he's capable of being
yeah
then you've got Travolta
but soon he started to Branch outside of
Comedians and fighters to a different
genre of people let's call them thinkers
workers don't have the right to engage
in collective bargaining in the United
States until the 1930s that's where that
whole idea of the let the market decide
falls apart you would have philosophers
on and politicians scientists you name
it the show started to become just a
grab bag of any interesting person Joe
Rogan wanted to have a conversation with
Neil deGrasse Tyson the astrophysicist
appeared a few times you get a
Multiverse
we didn't pull that out of our ass that
came out of the equations soon it was
bigger and bigger names Elon Musk
Russell Brand Nick Kroll Jay Leno Jordan
Peterson Wiz Khalifa Dr Phil Travis
Barker by the late 2010s The Joe Rogan
Experience was reaching around 11
million listeners per episode making it
the most popular podcast ever at least
on platforms like apple podcasts and
Spotify like I had never listened to
this but I knew of Joe Rogan because
he's kind of everywhere when you're
scrolling through any podcast app so
then in 2020 Spotify was like I want a
piece of this like giant popular podcast
and they bought the exclusive rights to
the podcast for 200 million dollars
which is unbelievably insane this was a
huge deal for Joe Rogan but also for
podcasts let's go even after this big
deal the show retained its unfiltered
quality it still was Joe Rogan sitting
around chatting with mostly dudes
talking openly and unfiltered for 4
hours you don't know what a bear is I've
seen a bear in the wild when you see the
bear in The Wild you're like oh you're
you don't give a [__] about me often
getting progressively more high with his
guest did people get upset at you if you
do certain things
tobacco and marijuana in there uh
I'm getting text messages from from from
Friends saying what the hell are you
doing smoking weed okay so my job has
apparently turned into getting super
deep into watching stuff that I never
watched before like North Korean films
and now Joe Rogan podcasts like I've
dedicated a significant amount of my
time over the past several months to
watching this show and even still I'm
just scratching the surface these
episodes are long they're like two and a
half hours on average and there are
almost 2 000 of them we're talking
thousands and thousands of hours of this
stuff luckily for this story I had help
from our story producer Alex to help us
listen to a lot of this stuff I also
spoke with some long time Joe Rogan
listeners for some insight and here in
the office we actually had some pretty
nice heated debates about Joe Rogan
[Music]
and now after my baptism by Joe Rogan I
now have some big takeaways some things
I want to say
number one Joe hates boxes and people
love videos she spends a lot of time
lambasting our society's need to fit
people into buckets into labels I think
this left white right Paradigm is really
kind of [__] foolish at this point
and indeed it's fairly impossible to put
Joe Rogan into the standard ideological
boxes that were all sort of pressured to
fit into most of our media discourse
loves boxes loves to inflame our super
identities the things that we must
believe in order to be a good liberal or
a good conservative what kind of
opinions are okay to have because they
don't interfere with anybody else's life
and it's just your philosophy and the
way you look at the world you should be
able to express that opinion and express
those ideas in front of someone else who
has an opposing idea and they tell you
why they disagree and so before I listen
to a million hours of the show I had
mostly seen Joe Rogan in the context of
like short little edited clips of like
smackdowns showing like some egregious
thing that Joe Rogan had said that he
was transphobic or fat phobic or
misogynistic or racist as a lot of these
mashups out there she's giant like look
at the size of her head her formerly
male head yeah that's a giant woman walk
into
we walked in dude we we walked in the
door and there was no white people there
was no white people
wow
that video is so bad it actually made me
miss the n-word video and when you watch
this stuff it's so easy to just like
slot him in to like oh he must be like
some Far Right sort of like racist
reactionary commentator so I was
surprised honestly when I listened to a
lot of this guy to find out that his
politics actually lean mostly left she's
the wife of the best president that we
have had in our life openly and
earnestly voices support for everything
from Universal Health Care to abortion
to gay marriage to recreational drugs
Eileen way left when it comes to those
kind of things gay rights and things
like social programs for disenfranchised
people and disenfranchised communities I
lean way like if I want my tax dollars
to go to anything I wanted to go to
making people's lives easier I'm not
right-wing at all oh okay that's wild no
there's nothing about me this right wing
even endorsed Bernie Sanders the
Democratic Socialist in 2020 after
having him on the show there's not a
single human that can speak for all the
American people but he could look out
for the interests of the American people
and I think Bernie Sanders definitely
does do do that you've got three people
owning more wealth in the bottom half of
the American society you don't see that
on television too much
no you don't three people you have to
top one percent owning more wealth than
the bottom ninety two percent what are
the misconceptions of you because here's
here's the if you go to the knee-jerk
conservative reaction you talk to people
who are not interested in anyone that
wants to be a Democratic Socialist they
hear the name Bernie Sanders the
negative implications are that you are
somehow or another going to take their
money right is that annoying to you yes
it is of course it is oh and here he is
with presidential hopeful Andrew Yang
agreeing with him on the super
Progressive idea of universal basic
income my initial knee-jerk reaction was
get out of here like Universal basic ink
I'm just going to give people money
they're just going to be lazy nothing's
ever going to get done that's a terrible
idea and then I started paying attention
to the rise of AI and Automation and how
many jobs are going to get taken away
and then once you see the actual numbers
it's pretty staggering but despite
thinking that he presents his ideas in
this very kind of of anti-woke
anti-political correctness say whatever
you want type of vibe and this is
confusing but also very appealing people
love to listen to a guy whose views and
language are all over the place I think
for a lot of people it's like a respite
from the predictable lineup of popular
voices that toe a predictable list of
beliefs opinions views and enemies
Rogan's style is rare and I think people
like that which gets me to my second big
takeaway
Joe Rogan sells contrarianism that is
his product a quick reminder that Joe
Rogan isn't just a guy he is a
commercial icon a seasoned performer who
performs for an audience for money he
knows what people want and he is selling
something very popular an alternative to
the endless reductionist polarized name
calling of our current discourse they
all do the same move they drop down and
do the splits that's what I think when
I'm watching your shows too you know all
the same stuff but and he goes to Great
Lengths to stake himself out as this
anti-authority anti-establishment
platform where anyone can come and talk
if you're in one Camp you're supposed to
have all the opinions that one Camp has
yeah and if you do not align with all
the opinions so that one Camp has you
find yourself cast out of the group no
woke police no mainstream media bias no
corporate deception just an Earnest
curious guy trying to find the truth and
not really worrying too much about
changing his language to fit the
politically correct sensitivities of the
day what I didn't anticipate was social
media and the echo chambers that it
would provide right and that these
ideological Echo Chambers also come with
virtue signaling and that people get on
these things because you're you only
dealing with a short amount of
characters and you state something that
you know is going to get a bunch of
likes and people are very addicted to
likes the fans I talk to love this about
Joe Rogan like he's like the antidote to
like the corporate mainstream stream
biased media that's polarizing us all
and frankly I think he leans into this
as his brand which gets me to my third
point and this is where I have my
biggest critique of Joe Rogan Joe lets
people talk and talk and talk and talk
the principles of human interaction on
this planet are largely dictated by our
ability to discuss things even if you
disagree as we've seen Joe has had a
huge variety of guests on his show a lot
of these are like famous people that you
just get to watch talk in this sort of
unfiltered way like Robert Downey Jr or
Miley Cyrus but then you also have a lot
of people with big opinions and big
points of view from Super mainstream and
respected voices to experts on like
really specific science things but then
you have a handful of a lot of
controversial Fringe characters people
who have been censored or canceled by
the mainstream media and honestly I
think Joe takes huge pride in having
this spectrum of different points of
view now I don't know Joe Rogan but my
guess is that half of this is his
personality he seems to be a guy who
loves to discuss things with people
seems to have an open mind but I think
half of this again is a response to the
upkeep of his brand I think he likes the
appeal of being this anti-mainstream
platform where anyone who has been
canceled by the woke mob can come and
get their Fair Shake tell their side of
the story I mean it's you don't have to
agree on on everything in order to have
a common sense of the important values
that that unify the country or should
and here comes my big critique I think
there's a fallacy tucked into all of
this
when Joe has these people on it almost
feels like he's giving them a chance to
tell their side of the story like they
don't have a place to to tell their side
and they've been unfairly censored I
think this is flawed thinking not
everyone who has a point of view and who
is famous has ideas worth hearing or
debating in our society I really believe
that there are people who've gotten
famous simply because they've made a
career off of being loud and mean and
human nature loves that for some reason
like here's a show with Gavin McGinnis I
started this gang called The Proud boys
and proud boys the proud boys what is
that what's proud boys about a far-right
extremist group that promotes white
supremacy ideology and proudly promotes
violence against groups they don't agree
with four members of The Proud boys that
far-right extremist organization well
they've been found guilty of seditious
conspiracy for their roles in the
January 6 attack on the capital like
here he is fondly remembering the time
his group violently at hacked people who
were protesting Milo yiannopoulos at
Berkeley he goes I started to feeling
batting I started feeling bad after a
while because I was just I could tell
these kids had never been in a fight and
I was just mowing through them
I mean I don't know like having a guy on
your show who espouses the view that
lenient immigration and abortion among
white women is leading to white genocide
in the west doesn't feel like fruitful
robust dialogue that will open all of
our minds and push the boundaries of our
discourse it feels like outraging people
with old tribal ideas to get attention
and this is my critique is like it feels
like sometimes Joe will have these
people on because they say and do
reprehensible things not in spite of it
I'm taking the low road I'm punching
them in the face so that's what you're
doing with this outfit yes they think
they can ruin his work because he jerked
off in front of some people you know I'm
not going to bow down before them and
say you were right and they want me to
but they weren't right I'm right I wrote
it [__] again his brand is the
anti-establishment place where you won't
get censored by the woke police but
listen Joe is absolutely right being
able to say things no matter how much I
disagree with them is a vital right it
is an unnatural and precarious thing
people should be able to speak and we
must protect that I believe that and Joe
should absolutely legally be allowed to
give his giant megaphone to whoever he
wants but that doesn't mean I'm not
going to critique it because listen
having this open-minded likable guy
who's very good at entertaining us give
his megaphone to other dudes who promote
violence who tear down science who
invent fake facts and talk about them
like they're real it doesn't promote
curiosity it normalizes lying it
validates factlessness which is
something that if you haven't heard we
already have a problem with we're
already battling that nuclear bombs
actually don't exist that uh they never
actually figured it out but they
realized that the the threat of nuclear
bombs is good enough but Eddie you can
see the bombs
and this feeling really hit me when I
was listening to the episode with Alex
Jones Alex Jones a man who has created
did an Empire off of promoting lies and
warped information so that he can sell
Health supplements our fertility is
being targeted and it's dropping Across
the Western World ladies and gentlemen
anthroplex is the newest addition at
infowarslife.com a man who was recently
ordered to pay 1.5 billion dollars in
damages to the families of the Sandy
Hook shooting victims for spreading lies
about the shooting being a hoax and yet
here he is on The Joe Rogan Experience
getting a chance to tell his side of the
story when I started getting accused
four years ago a couple years into it I
said no I think it happened then people
that I had interviewed and things
started saying he's involved he's one of
them because you are now saying that it
happened they thought that you had been
compromised yes and then I was realizing
oh
this is how it works certain percentage
of people are schizophrenic exactly and
then they just think everything's a
conspiracy now listen I'm going to tell
you the truth right now and admit
something which is that when I watched
this
I actually had a moment where I was like
oh my God like here's Alex Jones in this
like very calm environment he's like
yelling like he does on Infowars my
heart's big it's got hot blood going
through it fast I like to eat I like to
have children and I literally thought
like wait is Alex Jones like was he
wrongfully accused or was this overly
exaggerated was this like a Witch Hunt
to censor this guy because he's like
kind of has far right views because this
felt like a proper moment for Jones to
tell his side of the story I began to
realize because I was on the receiving
end of people pulling up in white Vans
with guns at my office saying I know you
put a microchip in my head I'm gonna
kill you so I came out and I said listen
I never sent anybody to the houses but I
apologize for taking out of context
people to write the question but I I'm
sorry for the families and I'm sorry for
your hurt and I get it and I've
experienced crazy people now big time
just like you have please stop saying
that I'm saying it didn't happen and he
nearly persuaded me but wait no
no then I remembered that my full-time
job is to do journalism no one died in
2012 in Sandy Hook and luckily I sit
around and fact check things all day and
I researched it and I reminded myself
that there's actually not a ton of
nuance here the facts Alex Jones
repeatedly claimed that the Sandy Hook
shooting was a staged event orchestrated
by the globalists the government to
promote gun control that's why the
globalists used children's deaths to go
after our guns because they know it gets
to us he suggested that The Grieving
parents were crisis actors and that no
children had actually died early on I
said well they had to kill somebody and
this doesn't make sense then parents
come out and start laughing and then
turn to the camera and Cry he's grieving
families who had experienced
unimaginable horror had to relocate
because of the harassment they received
in part due to Jones peddling of this
lie so that it could sell Health
supplements these are facts that are
available to all of us okay and yet I
don't know about you but if I weren't a
full-time journalist who was paid to go
down rabbit holes and check facts I'm
not sure would have gone and done this
I'm not sure it would have gone and
reviewed all of the facts and wrestled
with them in my mind especially not
after listening to two and a half hours
of Alex Jones talking I think the idea
of trusting your viewer to go fact check
everything you say is irresponsible and
naive I spend every day of my life
making sure that the things I tell you
are factually accurate if I get
something wrong it's a cardinal sin in a
world of algorithms and misinformation
and Russian Bots it becomes nearly
impossible to fact check everything you
see which is why we rely on trusted
voices to help us navigate the
information out there to help us
navigate what is real and what is not so
instead Alex Jones a man who makes money
off lies gets to tell his side of the
story and what does he do with his time
surprise he lies the amount of Sandy
Hook coverage against me has been so
insane and so huge because it's supposed
to be the first Domino the ones I'm
taking down that all the dominoes fall
he tells a story about how this was all
one big conspiracy to take him down now
of course there is more Nuance to this
conversation as usual Rogan does push
back a few times I don't think that's I
think the majority of them are angry
because the narrative has been that
you're sending people to these Sandy
Hook families Holmes but I guess I'm
wondering why why is this the person
that you want on your show Joe you're a
curious open-minded guy and you've
decided that this guy this guy's voice
is who deserves your megaphone to 11
million people and this doesn't even get
to the other hours that Jones has on
Rogan's show where he outlines his
theories on genetics and race Native
Americans you can mind control really
fast
hmm why is that
well it's like Vietnam so Asians are
about the most Fearless killers there
are Native Americans they're the best
out there they can do my use Native
Americans are the easiest to do mind
reading too because you know they're
like one unit Indonesians they're it's
just like so crazy oh and this clip has
less Nuance like if you listen to the
whole thing you're actually just
watching Alex Jones talking Non-Stop
about totally [__] theories on race
and genetics and Joe is just sitting
there nodding his head Native Americans
are gung-ho and they're tough and
they're ready to fight not you know I'm
part native American I'm only like six
percent Comanche and you know uh Texas
and just that little bit makes me wild
no they're not breaking any laws this is
their right but what the [__] this isn't
exploring both sides this isn't nuanced
conversation this is pretend information
framed as rigorous discussion echoing
ideas and thought processes that have
been used for centuries to divide and
demean people this isn't balanced
conversation it's faulty logic and
factlessness disguised as discourse I
have no respect for it and listen Joe
Rogan wouldn't disagree with me fully on
this he knows that putting people on his
show helps them helps their ideas and by
the way I'm not a trump supporter in any
way shape or form I've had the
opportunity to have them on my show more
than once I've said no every time I
don't want to help him this isn't the
Public Square this isn't a personal
conversation between friends sharing
ideas this is a powerful man who
commands the attention of millions of
people he has decisions on who he gives
his megaphone to and who he does not and
what facts he decides to challenge and
which he does not okay wait but I'm not
done there's Nuance to my critique which
is that sometimes letting people with
ideas that I find reprehensible talk
is actually really good most of Joe
Rogan's guests are not Alex Jones
they're honestly interesting stimulating
conversations with a lot of really
interesting people and even the ones I
disagree with there is so much value in
letting them talk like I listened to
this two-hour conversation with Candace
Owens a political pundit who I deeply
disagree with I mean she's called Trump
the savior of Western Civilization she's
called black lives matter a bunch of
whiny toddlers pretending to be
oppressed for attention I deeply
disagree with this woman after listening
to the show with Candace Owens I still
deeply disagree with Candace Owens in
fact I found more reasons to reject her
approach to politics and facts so let's
say we all agree that global warming is
real I don't believe it's real okay so I
can't say but that's the question but
why have a belief
what do you mean why have a belief as to
whether or not global warming is real or
not real because I just I just find that
when things are correct but crucially
suddenly what I couldn't do was hate her
like was so easy before it's really hard
to hate someone when you listen to them
speak I received some voicemail messages
from about four kids and that like you
know the language was it was pretty
strong it was like we're in a tar and
feather your family we're gonna put a
bow in the back of your head like we did
to Martin Luther King like you know N
word N word n word you inconveniently
have to see them as a real human with
feelings and thoughts and ideas and it
becomes a lot harder to just put them
into a bucket as someone I should hate
which of course as we all know is a huge
thing that we've lost in our world of
echo Chambers where we only hear from
people that we agree with and when we do
hear from people we disagree with it's
often framed in an outrageous
click-baity article linked on Twitter
entitled watch the senator that you
agree with destroy the person you
disagree with and reinforce your views
that they are a monster and that you are
justified in hating them this is how I
knew Candace Owens before I listened to
her speak for two hours but now I see
her as a person a human who holds views
that I see is objectively bad for people
and our society but I can't dehumanize
her somebody started doing this prank
calling [__] on you and was this it was
all in one night it was all in one yeah
I was like four voices it was tied to
like a boyfriend
a boyfriend's house when I got the calls
and I just like put to silence it was
like block number so I was like I didn't
think anything of it and then like when
I listened to it like it was like some
pretty horrific stuff like I definitely
cried you know I was 17 years old and
this gets me to my last takeaway and
then we'll finish up this video which is
that Joe Rogan models curiosity and
openness and this is valuable it is rare
and unique to watch a tough guy Fighter
TV host dirty comedian with a microphone
admit that he's wrong here's the thing
these like planned statements let's be
real clear I don't have an off air and
on-air voice I don't no I have me this
is it you typically don't see stuff like
this do I get things wrong absolutely I
get things wrong but I try to correct
them and when it comes to powerful men
in this world most of the loudest voices
are the ones promoting a confident Macho
nightmare version of masculinity nobody
would be tougher on Isis than Donald
Trump and while they don't Vibe with all
of the ways that Joe expresses his
manhood
I think he is a Force for good in this
department in showing an eagerness to
ask questions and an ability to change
his mind and yet as I mentioned earlier
my critique is that I think he overuses
this Persona this confident curious
Persona of I don't know anything I'm not
an expert like if you say you disagree
with me I probably disagree with me too
when I say something stupid I'm not
thinking about what I'm going to say
before I say it I'm just saying it to
tacitly validate deceiving information
and to give voice to opportunistic
characters and so in the end I'm not
really sure if this modeling of an open
mind outweighs the proliferation of
seductively fake facts and ideas
especially in a time where truth and
facts are already scarce and Under Siege
and creating confusion for all of us
dude they're keeping they have human
animal hybrids there's the freaking I
have been there when people that work
for the Pentagon say that they we go to
the laboratory and we meet with the
Ambassador we have to take higher and
higher doses to meet with them they're
giving us in the technology worked I
don't even think it's clear that carbon
dioxide is actually a problem but we can
leave that aside they say that that 80
percent of kids who experience any sort
of gender dysphoria as children grow out
of it this tension is not unique to
Rogan all media all news outlets are
subject to this seductive temptation to
appeal to the worst parts of our nature
Rogan's version of it is unique because
he and his show are unique so for how
much I disagree with some of his
standards and fact-checking habits I do
take comfort in this guy's commitment to
openness to curiosity Joe Rogan is a
powerful man who changes his mind who
admits when he's wrong which I think is
a much needed counterbalance in an
increasingly polarized world
and sometimes the best way to combat bad
speech is to let that speech play out
and let good speech overwhelm it with
logic and reason and a better argument
but if they admit that they're wrong
then they're also admitting that they
have horribly disfigured and abused
thousands maybe millions of kids how
many people have had this done
depends on what I don't think we have
exact numbers but it's if we're talking
about the drugs it's I mean Millions it
says over the last five years there were
at least 4 780 adolescents who started
puberty blockers and at a prior gender
dysphoria diagnosis a million sounds
great
yeah Wi-Fi radiation
is uh it does all kinds of bad things
including causing cancer Wi-Fi radiation
causes yeah from your cell phone I mean
their cell phone tuner tumors you know
that I mean I'm representing hundreds of
people who have cell phone tumors behind
the ear it's always on the ear that you
favor with your cell phone
hey everyone
thanks for watching my big long video
essay on Joe Rogan I'm thinking about
this one for a long time
um let me tell you about a couple of
things uh first off
I made a poster a physical product a
thing that exists in the real world
after a decade of making things that
only exist in pixels so look
this is a poster called all maps are
wrong it's a bunch of different map
projections all the different
mathematical ways that we can show the
world which is a sphere
on a flat plane this is a poster that
you can purchase and put on your wall
and help support this channel which is
very appreciated for other ways to
support the channel you can look at The
Newsroom The Newsroom is our patreon
where our Newsroom members support us
and they get in exchange an extra video
every month which is a behind the scenes
Vlog all of the shenanigans and the
methods and the people and the processes
and the everything that we do here in
the studio recapture and we put into a
vlog that you can watch but really it's
about supporting what we're trying to do
here which is independent journalism
which takes a lot of time and resources
we also have Luts and presets Luts are
how we color our video presets or how I
color photos we develop these with a
professional colors and they're very
good and you can buy them support the
channel and use them first off if you're
new around here and you're still
watching the video you must be super
into what we're doing here like you're
at the very end of like a super long
video and you're still watching and
you're new around here
you should probably subscribe all right
bye
go get out of here dude